[Music]
hello dr alakam
and
in 10 minutes
thank you for joining and meanwhile we
begin i would like to hear from you
about your
research and trust and also
your background
you can put it in the chat box
looking forward to
hear from you
okay
hello everyone i would like to welcome
to
judge joy
uh we'll be waiting for everyone to join
and
then we'll be starting in five more
minutes
thank you for joining
and meanwhile we begin with the
webinar
it would be great to hear from you about
your research interest and your
educational background as well
please feel free to put in the chat box
about your interests and
your background
also if you have any questions you can
please
put them in the chat box
hello everyone i would like to welcome
those who have just joined we'll be
starting in more two minutes we are
waiting for others to join as well
very warm good morning good afternoon or
good evening in whichever part of the
world you are so let's begin with
today's webinar i would first of all
like to welcome you all to this webinar
we'll be talking about uh the summer
training programs
that will be starting from next week so
today we are going to talk about
introduction to bioinformatics
omixologic transcriptomics chemi
informatics and structural biology and
also the industry academia fellowship
with omixlogic under mental guidance
so before we start talking about each
one of these programs
i would just like to quickly introduce
us for the ones who have joined us for
the very first time
so we are a us-based bioinformatics
company who is working with multiple
academic and commercial collaborators to
develop easy to use analytical tools and
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
the training has been completed by over
24 000 participants from 187 countries
in over 350 workshops and due to this
fast growth our team is working with
local and regional coordinators that are
helping refine the local program
logistics and leverage our online
training resources adapting them to the
needs of students and researchers around
the world
the omixlodger training follows a
project based learning approach which
uses research great tools to analyze
data from top peer reviewed journals
army social training has been completed
by six different specialization tracks
in oncology infectious diseases
precision medicine neuroscience data
science for biomedical data and
comprehensive training on omics data
analysis
now i would like to introduce our team
founders and co-founders as well dr
alfred tauber comes from a medical
background with an expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
information and one of his major
projects is the establishment of the
topper bioinformatics research center
which has been at the core of what we do
doctor yurin brodsky is the director of
tribal bioinformatics research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics our platform is a result
of hard work by some of the people who
are mentioned here on the right julia
panoff is an expert
aviator duffsky leads the development of
the t by info platform dr mohit mazumdar
is an experienced bioinformatician with
multiple publications in peer review
journals and he has been developing
collaborations with universities as a
mentor guide and project lead for
homicide training and research
fellowship dr raghavendra lakshmi
narayanan is an accomplished
computational biologist with an
experience in large scale analysis of
multi-omics data and data science
methods in precision oncology and
protein dna structural bioinformatics i
am sonalika rihanna and the omislogic
community manager and i am responsible
for daily interaction with thousands of
users that are a part of our team
uh buying biotech
to introduce
her she's our sales executive and she'll
be helping you enroll in any of the
programs that you are interested in and
ojasi helps us with the web analytics
so today let's talk about bioinformatics
first and we'll also discuss about the
programs the structure and the resources
that you can leverage the most
so what is bioinformatics
it is the development implementation and
usage of methods and software tools for
understanding biological data
bioinformatics has practical
applications in healthcare agriculture
and mitigating climate change
as this field progresses bioinformatics
poses several challenges for both
students trying to learn it and
difficulty trying to teach it
so in this presentation i will explain
the current challenges and limitation of
bioinformatics i would describe how we
aim to address these challenges with the
omicrologic learn portal i would
describe the army bloom's taxonomy for
learning progression and how it can be
used in bioinformatics coursework we'll
explore the omnislogic portal and how it
utilizes the bloom's taxonomy in
structuring its courses pipelines and
projects and finally describes several
outcomes of the onyx logic book
so what are some of the challenges that
the field of bioinformatics is currently
facing to begin this field is constantly
growing and developing new tech and
software to improve processing time and
power the data sets that are analyzed
are usually very large and take immense
amounts of computing power and memory
that many personal computers do not have
also despite being publicly available
data are also usually complex to access
and coding knowledge is usually required
to do so
similarly analysis pipelines and
programs required to do so
in a university setting students have
the opportunity to learn the background
information of designing and
implementing a bioinformatics project
but do not receive practical hands-on
experience with full workflow due to the
limitations mentioned previously
similarly faculty faces the challenges
similarly faculty faces the challenges
with being able to cover a diverse range
of topics if they are specialized in a
certain area of bioinformatics or if
they are unfamiliar with bioinformatics
in general for example a professor whose
research focuses on oncogene expression
might not know about the metagenomics of
sea water and to overcome these
challenges the omixlogic portal was
developed this program aims to
standardize organize and systematize
bioinformatics training in order to make
these analysis usable for any biologist
or clinician
there are some traditional problems with
the standardization of bioinformatics
coursework materials for courses are
usually developed in-house taught
sporadically and are rarely updated the
omixlogic portal introduces new material
that keeps up with new technology these
courses also need to be organized
because the challenge is to combine
several different topics together the
flow and transition between subjects
needs to be developed and this is
addressed at omit logic through
introductory material being woven
throughout course
the last challenge we face is
systematization how can you know that
someone is stuck and needs help or
allows someone to run forward to address
this omics celtric uses standardized
modules and interactive sessions
beginning with mastering terminology and
concepts to implementing these concepts
with the real data sets in a project
based approach
here is an overview of the learning
process in order to create a clear path
of skill development omics logic employs
the bloom's taxonomy levels of learning
this approach starts with the basics
students recall facts and terminology
and are able to repeat and memorize the
material
with the base the learning builds to
conceptual knowledge being able to
understand concepts and apply
information to new situations the
students will then be able to analyze
data by drawing connections and evaluate
when to use certain methods this leads
them to the highest level of learning
the ability to design and create
original work
so how do omixologic resources help
advance bioinformatics
omix logic is a portal for practical and
theoretical learning of bioinformatics
composed of courses designed to take you
through the theoretical knowledge omix
larger takes a combination of training
models data analysis tools curated
project data
and interactive sessions with mentors to
give a student a clear path up the
bloom's astronomy pyramid no matter what
the user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is omixlogic is a useful
tool for gaining a baseline knowledge of
the theory behind bioinformatics
analysis of large data sets and
introduction to basic coding languages
like r and python or beginning a data
analysis project altogether
these six courses
that we'll be talking about in this
slide were taken from the core omics
logic curriculum which is available
online beginning with an introduction to
the applications of bioinformatics and
an overview of data types the student is
able to learn terminology and factual
knowledge to build upon from there
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics and data science are
introduced each course starts with
important terms and concepts and then
introduces case studies and pipelines
related to each other and this allows
the students to gain conceptual
knowledge in order to begin their own
projects
omixlogic expands upon its basic
curriculum with specialization track
projects bioinformatics methods are best
learned in the context of real case
studies which are prepared by our
network of mentors and collaborators
that illustrate how various
bioinformatics methods and honesty data
types are used in current research in
medicine biotechnology agriculture and
even astrobiology and the projects are
prepared by taking publicly available
data sets and using them to explore and
understand both the research challenge
and also the analysis parts to extract
meaningful insights from complex omics
data
the portal gives students the options
for analyzing a given data set
code dependent paths or code independent
parts
these data sets at associated
publications can be used in several ways
you can learn bioinformatics without any
coding at all
for that in each project we explain the
analysis pipelines on the user-friendly
tbio info platform for big data analysis
in a while we'll be taking you through
the portal as well you can also learn
the scripts behind many of the steps
learning to wrangle clean visualize and
analyze data in popular languages like r
and python in order to create your own
analysis
finally you can hear about the projects
and their research applications in our
mental guided programs where it's first
share their experience and support
research projects which are developed by
you
now here is an example of the code
independent pipeline
the pipeline builder interface on the
team bioinfo platform is a color coded
pipeline that helps establish a logical
connection between the technical names
of data analysis methods and the logical
steps that are needed to build a full
pipeline
data is put in as an input file and that
analysis can be chosen based off of the
type of research each analysis is
separated into three colors
blue for pre-processing red for mapping
and green for quantification each time
you click a button a pop-up will contain
additional information which is useful
for building the pipeline the ease of
color-coded buttons allow programs to be
run without any coding knowledge
interactive outputs allow each
visualization of the data
several demo pipelines with real data
sets are available for students to
practice the workflow including demos on
genomic variant calling for cancer cell
lines 16 is amplicon sequencing
analysis on diet and its effect on the
microbiome and a pipeline for examining
a phylogenetic analysis of ebola virus
shortly we'll be taking you through
these demo pipelines as well
now after using the t bioinfo platform
to visualize the pipelines and practice
analyzing students are then able to take
their theoretical knowledge the remember
and understanding levels of groups and
apply that in a project the apply
analyze and evaluate levels of clues
then train their comprehension with
levels of um with different levels and
badges certificates of completion and
test
similarly faculty should be able to
assign the omixojic portal to their
students
and also design a holistic and
comprehensive knowledge of
bioinformatics beginning with bytes and
molecules and onto designing their own
question based project
omixlogic employs a hybrid approach
combining learning and research and to
ensure that
the students are building off of the
first level of bloom's taxonomy
omics launcher tracks progress with
activities like pipelines coding and
literature reviews quizzes on topics key
terms and important questions and covers
a broad range of topics like biomedical
research biotechnology and agriculture
then students are able to continue their
knowledge base with the research
assessment making sure they are able to
understand methods challenges and
results as well as being able to
comprehend primary
primary research literature and recreate
the methodology
they should be able to ask questions
based on data exploration and this leads
to the ability to encounter errors in
their analysis apply theoretical
knowledge of why those errors are
occurring and find a solution
bioinformatics combines life science
terms with data science skills which
allows researchers to answer life
science questions with reproducible data
analysis methods
the portal we are proud to collaborate
with many diverse programs across the
globe we also work with over 24 000
students at community colleges like
glendale community college top tier
universities like georgetown university
as well as 20 universities around the
world
and
if you want to learn more about it then
you can definitely get started
on the amis logic learn portal which is
absolutely free and anyone can register
for free with many courses available
and now
let's begin by talking about the
different summer programs that we wanted
to discuss in this free webinar so to
begin with i would now like to pass on
the stage to mr ilia brodsky uh mr elia
broski ceo pine biotech could not make
up for the meeting and he has shared
with us a recording and i would like to
invite mr ojasi dutta to please play
that recording for us
just me can you show your screen
yes
[Music]
uh
we can share the slack link or just give
us a couple of minutes we'll be sharing
over to you or just
bioinformatics is the intersection of
informatics or the science of processing
data for storage and retrieval
and biology the study of living
organisms
why should you care about bioinformatics
there are a few reasons for that even if
you're not in computer science or i.t
more and more data is being generated in
the research and biomedical fields
this includes agriculture biotechnology
and biomedical research so knowing what
kinds of data are being generated and
how it is being analyzed will bring
value to your personal career and the
ability to collaborate effectively with
others
so let's briefly talk about what is
bioinformatics
bioinformatics is a conversion of
biology
and data where both are equally
important as we will see in the next few
slides
who uses bioinformatics and who is this
for
the answer might have been statisticians
computer scientists or engineers
but the truth is that more and more
biologists and clinicians are now
expected to understand and handle their
own data
and to publish and succeed in basic and
translational research as well as
industry
in fact you can say today that biology
itself is rapidly acquiring
the characteristics of a data science
this field developed tremendously in the
last several decades
basically transforming life sciences
enabling technology and empowering
biomedical research at scale
as a result
many new discoveries that include new
treatments diagnostic assays design
strategies for experimentation were
discovered and perfected
as a result there is a growing interest
among biologists and clinicians in data
including new types of data generation
like different types of omix
technologies
new methods of computational analysis
as well as approaches that allow us to
mine complex data to find patterns that
can explain biological phenomena
a lot of breakthroughs in bioinformatics
are a result of the growth and adoption
of high throughput technologies
these technologies generate
billions of data points on genes
proteins and other many molecules that
can characterize biological systems how
they function
and
what are the different variations from
normal
or different types of clinical
conditions that we can describe using
these techniques the data are
complicated but they're organized and
compiled into repositories that can be
systematically studied to understand
interrogate and establish trends
for many different applications
one such repository is maintained by the
national center for biotechnology
information which has a collection of
peer-reviewed articles biological data
sets and projects on a variety of topics
introduction to bioinformatics is a
program that is designed to introduce
you to these important terms and topics
so after completing the course you will
be able to see the applications of next
generation sequencing
biostatistical methods of analysis and
other computational tools that are used
to process and mine big data such as
machine learning
more importantly the program is more
than just a theoretical introduction
it's really a practical course
it will give you a sense of what types
of technologies are used and we call
them omix technologies
what kinds of analytical methods are
used by people in the industry and in
research to analyze and interrogate
these data sets and most importantly you
will have access to a portal and a
community that will support your journey
so the training program is going to be
run through this omics logic portal and
the armix logic portal combines many
important elements that you need to
succeed as a beginner in bioinformatics
it gives students options for analyzing
a data set
based on codependent paths or code
independent paths so you can pursue
bioinformatics by learning coding
languages like r and python or you can
choose to just understand the logic of
analysis by not necessarily dedicating
time to that the portal offers many
different ways to study biology using
data at different levels complexity
so what you will find
is a way to get started then identify a
type of data a type of omics data like
genomics epigenomics or others and then
pursue potentially a more technical
skill enrichment path that might include
coding and statistical analysis but you
can also skip those and especially focus
on projects which are publications
designed to introduce you to a real
scientific challenge that you can study
using data
you will find collections of training
modules that are organized under this
getting started collection
so the program is designed to point you
to the level of relevant resources and
complete them over the course of the
program that we are going to start
the resources will introduce
bioinformatics applications in
healthcare biomedical research
biotechnology and agriculture
provide you with a concise overview of
various biological concepts that you
need to know to understand omics data
introduce you to big data analysis using
several example data sets and expose you
to some coding in r in python so that
you are aware of how the analysis of
biological data is done behind the
scenes
this learning process will go from the
bottom the basic level of bloom's
taxonomy to the top of this pyramid
and the process goes from
understanding and remembering
terminology to then learning how to
apply these tools to use information in
new situations then draw connections
among ideas and eventually be able to
evaluate and even create new analyses
using the tools that you will be
introduced to
and these are just several examples that
lead to more in-depth review of key
topics technologies and analysis methods
so the program being an introduction
will give you high level introduction
into all of these topics genomics such
as variant calling transcriptomics such
as gene expression analysis metagenomics
analysis of the microbiome or
communities of bacteria and viruses
epigenomics regulation of gene
expression using
non-genomic coding
and an introduction to data science how
do you apply data visualization analysis
and machine learning to study these
complex data sets and integrate them
importantly after this overview you will
be introduced to the concept of
omixlogic projects
these projects are focused around the
areas of oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience and agriculture and you
will be able to pick a project that you
can follow as a tutorial or potentially
design a project of your own after the
program is over
you will also be introduced to the t
bioinfo platform for big data analysis
where you can run analysis of large data
without any technical challenges
understand the logic of specific
pipelines and produce different usable
results that you can visually explore
and understand trends in the data that
you have
so to see the full schedule we welcome
you to stay in the session ask questions
and really go through each session so
that you can start your journey in
bioinformatics
thank you so much for just for playing
the video for us
now that you know about the introduction
to bioinformatics coursework it's time
to learn more about the next program
that is transcriptomic data analysis and
to talk more about it i would like to
invite dr dragoventrin over to you dr
raghav
thank you
thank you very much
let's get my
screen sharing going
can you see my screen
i hope yeah i got confirmation that you
can see in the screen yes we can see us
okay perfect then we are in sync
oh sorry okay so hello everybody one
more time i'm raghavindran omix logic
mentor for big data bioinformatics
and i welcome you all to this part of
the webinar where i am going to
introduce you to one of the omics logic
specialization training program
transcriptomics data analysis so in this
program we will learn how to use
transcriptomics data
it's a second yeah transcriptomics data
to understand the biology of the system
from multitude of dimensions to cite a
few uh the transcriptomics data analysis
can identify and validate disease
targets we can explore the variation of
gene expression pattern in the natural
systems biology context and etc etc
so technically you will learn to
you will learn to employ different
analytical methods and reference
databases to understand how
gene expression vary across many
different conditions to do so
effectively you will also learn how
bioinformation generally leverage big
data processing methods that are
organized into bioinformatics pipelines
you will also learn to perform
exploratory data analysis normalization
techniques and apply statistical methods
for rigorous hypothesis testing and in
the end you will also be introduced to
advanced statistical methods like
machine learning algorithms that is
employed when the complexity of the data
that you deal with increases multitude
so now a lot of this is based on our
mixed data which can be studied using
omix technologies like next generation
sequencing technologies to explore the
roles relationships and actions of
various
types of models that make up the cells
of an organism the term omics can refer
to different types of data that can
include phenophenomics data meaning the
phenotypic data that can
refer to the cell morphology for example
we can also talk about genomics data to
characterize significant variations in
nucleotide and amino acid sequences
another type of data that is growing
rapidly is the epigenomics data which
deals with non-hereditary regulation of
gene activities that act without or that
act independently of the changes in
genomic or gene sequences and finally we
will be focusing uh
finally what we will be focusing on in
this program is transcriptomics data
analysis which is an important part
because it provides a real in-depth view
of how we can use gene expression and
isoform expression patterns to
understand cell phenotypes
so transcriptomic studies can be
performed by measuring the rna
translation of a cell in any given
instant so to measure the rna
translation transcriptomic studies
detect the mrna expression inside the
cell as an accurate alternative to
measure protein expression this allows
for molecular precision in diagnostics
and uh and even development of treatment
based on the molecular pathways that we
are characterizing that are
understanding so the mrna measurements
can be performed using targeted
technologies like microarray
technologies which provides measurements
for probes targeting a set of genes
are a more advanced high throughput
technology like next generation
sequencing technology that measures all
the mrna that is present inside the cell
so this technology rna-seq technology
has revolutionized the way uh in which
biobiologists examine the transcriptomes
and has been extremely successful um
and has been extremely successfully
applied uh in biological research in
drug discovery in clinical development
to name a few
so this can actually measure the
expression levels of thousands and
thousands of genes simultaneously and
provide insights into functional
pathways regulatory networks in a
systems biological context so in
addition to this rna-seq technology and
rna-seq data can provide novel insights
into alternative splicing unannotated
exons novel transcripts
to name a few most importantly such a
detailed analysis method and such
detailed examination
will yield significant discoveries in
many research areas and has already
proven
uh to be yielding uh
more and more novel discoveries in many
research areas
for example yeah so we will talk about
in this program so what we will talk
about in this program is our ability to
leverage this kind of big data and see
the significance of gene expression
patterns in association with clinical
data this can help us identify molecular
biomarkers for diagnostics and for
therapy selections so new discoveries
include better understanding of complex
diseases at subcellular level as well as
target identification for novel drug
discovery and repurposing of the drugs
that is
already in circulation so in addition to
this you will also find many interesting
and important biomedical projects that
can leverage rnac data for diagnostics
and cancer biology
to understand the diagnostics and
biology of the cancer and for disease
classification and patient
stratification which are also important
for clinical trials and for
understanding of real patient population
that need to be treated uh as well as
using um
employing single cell and tissue
composition you know
in a multi uh in a heterogeneous tissue
uh environment so in this program we
will introduce you to several exemplar
projects that we have prepared using
publicly available rna-seq data to study
for example the role of tumor micro
environment in immunotherapy
to study the effectiveness of drug
repurposing in mounting defense against
pathogens and to understand different
types and subtypes of subtypes of tumor
tissues and to employ disease
stratification to accurate for accurate
diagnostics and also to
perform patient certification to
understand the response of the patient
to typical treatment or to
different treatment options and even to
find marker cells and tissue types in
neurodegenerative diseases
so the basic logic behind these types of
projects and these types of analysis is
to identify differentially expressed
genes in in an in an altered state or in
an altered disease condition versus
controlled experiments and this will
help us to analyze and to identify and
to find uh these genes and to um
and to find markers of cells and tissue
types that can be associated with the
different phenotypes of the samples so
to help you master the transcriptomics
data analysis we will cover these topics
and these can be and the topics that can
be categorized into six major steps we
will be combining the logic of analysis
uh with practical hands-on assignment
that will allow you to understand and
practice methods of analysis
and types of interpretation that we can
perform on rna-seq data on real-world
examples so in conclusion you will also
be able to plan how to take what you
have learned and apply to an independent
research project
project using tools and methods we have
covered in this specific program
so we will combine for this program we
will combine online sessions self-guided
study material and practical assignment
for an immersive experience that has
already proven extremely effective in
our respected omics logics program and
very well known other uh experiences
the turbot bioinfo platform is designed
with a vision to make bioinformatics
accessible and useful without the
requirement to learn coding that exclude
non-experts and make conventional tasks
extremely burdensome so in addition to
online courses all participants will get
access to hands-on exercises and data
sets for practice
and these can be completed without any
coding as i mentioned using the
analytical tbio info platform that
provides an interactive learning
experience the platform itself is color
coded to help establish a logical
connection between theoretical aspects
and different steps of data analysis
methods that you will be explained and
that you will be introduced to
these practical steps needs to be uh
yeah these practical steps that are
needed to be performed to achieve
biologically interpretable results that
we will uh also get our hands on
so the output of these analysis
pipelines are offered as an interactive
visualization
are offered as a means of tables and
graphics that will help users to
understand the way data can be
used to understand patterns and to and
can help you
start asking data-driven questions about
biological phenomena or about some
specific clinical condition that you are
studying
so we welcome you to join this program
and earn a certificate of excellence in
transcriptomic data analysis i hope to
meet
all of you or most of you and interact
with many of you in this program and for
now i will hand over the stage to dr
mohit to speak about chemi informatics
and structural biology over to you dr
mohan and thank you very much for your
attention
hello everyone uh thank you dr
raghavendran is my screen visible can
you confirm as an is it in for the full
screen mode
yes we can see it in the full screen
mode
all right great hello everyone it's so
it's it's really good to see you all
here today in the session and uh today
before i tell you more about the next
programs i just wanted to go for a quick
review that uh in in april we have
started our summer training programs
which are specially designed
for those who wants to start their
journey in uh into these different areas
of research by using these different
technologies and the training material
and uh the sessions that we are
that we have put together
so um starting from introduction to
bioinformatics is a beginner level
course that we discussed and ogisp has
shared the link
for the curriculum for the entire
curriculum including the sessions the
live sessions that we have planned
as well as
the
resources which are associated with each
of these sessions so one of the
advantages of omix logic programs are
like the association of online sessions
in and the asynchronous coursework which
is associated with each of the session
where all the topics that we go through
and we discussed are going to also be
covered in the asynchronous material so
that you can learn on your own and uh
you can have more questions uh in the q
and a live sessions so we have planned
uh omix logic introduction to
bioinformatics transcriptomics and then
chem informatics and the research
fellowship program that many of you you
are interested in which is to work on
projects so starting with the first
program uh of uh that i am going to
discuss is the came informatics program
and i saw that someone
here is interested in
molecular docking and drug discovery and
looking into the three-dimensional
structures and understanding them more
and connecting them with the
with the different
biological
problems that to solve so i mean to
ensure the likelihood of the best
results
researchers from the biotechnology
pharmacy and the life science industry
right now are utilizing molecular
technologies that are private to enable
the next era of personalized medicine so
that's where we are heading so due to
this fast growth in data generation
and ability of big data on public
repositories
these fields of computational structural
biology
and chem informatics are really evolving
at a rapid pace that is enabling
researchers to establish you know
biomolecular sequence to structure to
function relationships using fundamental
principles of physical sciences
and where these technologies are tools
such as chemi informatics which uses
algorithms and computational methods
using
molecular modeling and simulations to
mimic biological events and dynamics so
uh what it is enabling is that we we can
now kind of uh model from uh
two-dimensional sequence level to a
three-dimensional model and even uh
think about
the
functional relationship and design uh
strategies to overcome um you know
problems such as drug resistance or
finding a new drug so these ideas i mean
how they came in uh for km informatics
and especially
in the field of graphics
is is has to do a lot with you know
computer sciences so let's not
forget that that this is all because of
the organization processing and
the capabilities that has evolved during
the last
few years and like especially since 2020
there has been a phenomenal demand to
increase the use of bioinformatics chem
informatics and the use of machine
learning so i think that is one of the
reasons that many of you have joined
this session and are interested in
learning about these research topics but
along i mean just not about the
understanding of the research topics but
what we have been doing at our end is to
design
industry
related curriculums so that anyone can
learn about these research topics and
could use them as a skill set uh for
their own research or for opportunities
which are
related to job and internships
so
about the curriculum so this program
itself is designed for beginners so
anyone like students and faculty and
researchers who are eager to learn about
this fascinating field of computational
structural biology and chem information
so this collaborative training is
prepared and it will be delivered by
leaders in the various biotechnology and
pharma industry to address the need of
you know to address this need to
introduce students and researchers to
utilize public repositories and open
source tools to develop quality research
projects using structural biology
analysis applying chem informatics tools
so the
interested students researchers will
also have an opportunity to learn about
the application of r and python so we
will cover that in you know
in our asynchronous session so let me
tell you more about the sessions how
they are planned uh but before that like
as i was telling you that this program
will be led by mentors of omix logic
industry expert panel uh which is a very
elite panel of uh experts from
pharmaceutical industry as well as the
drug discovery industry so these are the
people who are really working there and
i have a hands-on experience years of
experience actually so this training is
designed to enable the student to learn
about the basic concepts of structural
biology and also to start applying and
working and utilizing specialized
algorithms and tools that have been
utilized by the industry and also the
research labs to innovate to discover
and find answers to
some of the important biological
questions so about the sessions as i'm i
was telling you that this kind of uh
starts with a very beginner level
because uh one of our experiences has
been that many students would want to
learn this from a basic uh from the very
basics and could
develop really specialized skill sets
understanding the direction
so the first session
and this would be the first session
which is about the introduction to
computational structural biology where
we are going to cover some of the
important uh biological we will go into
some of the important biological
repositories but before that we will
look into the history and techniques of
uh you know
the techniques
involved in
deciphering all these structures and
involving structural biology will
understand protein protein interaction
structural motives and uh
the conformational folding and all of
that so i mean the topics are arranged
in a way that uh you understand from a
very uh beginners perspective and then
grow different expertise while learning
and applying chem informatics and
structural biology so after learning
about those basic tools like uh how do
you visualize how do you find data what
are the repositories like pdb
and uh
and you are looking at uh motives cath
and all of that you
then we move to chem informatics session
by dr puneet kakar who is an industry
analyst manager at accenture and has a
phd in drug discovery so dr cooker will
be talking about uh it will be
introducing you to chemical interaction
chemical data basically so it will be a
in overview of chem informatics and uh
chem informatics and drug discovery
pipeline uh then key businesses in chem
informatics and then there is a hands-on
session on chemical space exploration so
we have with this program hands-on
session with all of the sessions um
where we have already
prepared um materials that will be
shared with the participants so in this
session we will cover some of the new
technologies discuss about what we have
now uh with the
uh advancements such as the
introduction of tools such as alpha fold
from google deepmind
to do the predictions more and more
accurately and also to utilize this vast
database and build our own structure of
need if if that is required and also to
understand that how um these uh
effect of different mutations that we
are learning about can be um done
computationally to gain insight and
develop more meaningful experiments
when it comes to
planning experiments in the wet lab
so gaining those insights and utilizing
the
tools which are available and i also
have a comparative understanding of how
different tools work and how some of the
questions could be answered by utilizing
these variety of
a variety of tools with different
algorithms that are meant to solve
specific biological problems so followed
by that we have the fourth session after
you after that after you learn about the
structural biology basics and gem
informatics and then structure
prediction and visualization
you will learn about this big data
repositories for virtual screening
basically so there is a hands-on session
on data warrior and visualizing
for ucsf chimera
and then there is this
practical session on
on docking
so after learning about the repositories
you before that you learn about the
tools and before that you learn about
the very basics now you're moving to the
place where we are you know doing
experiments and simulating creating this
accumulating environment to do molecular
docking so after this session we have
another session which focuses on machine
learning a little bit like how these
repositories
and how do you filter them properly to
find and create so small repositories
with more uh meaningful uh structures
um i mean many of them many of at this
stage many of the knowledge is driven by
by chemistry so medicinal chemistry
perhaps so this uh this information and
how do you how do aai is now playing a
role in here so we are going to use some
specific
tools such as data warfare and uh you
can google it and uh check that out it
is a visualization tool and also you can
do a lot of filters filteration to find
out uh there are several
more tools and features that are evolved
involved in it so followed by that like
once you have learned about all of this
now it also makes sense to think about
in the aspect of how does this all make
sense in the in the in aspect of a
project so designing a chem informatics
research project so how does that work
what you need to know and what are the
different components stages and the
challenges and then
we have another follow-up program in
july and uh in june and july that would
be
more of an advanced chemical informatics
which is to work on research projects
and develop
some um
using some advanced tools and some data
sets which are bigger in size
so uh all of this programs
and that we have discussed has a
support through the
through the asynchronous coursework so
that will be available with this and
also the expert sessions so there's an
expert session on drug repurposing by
doctor udesena he's a co-founder of a
startup company called region innovation
and uh he has huge experience of
working in big pharma companies such as
pfizer
and worked with a team that had
discovered liporter
and he has been working with us for a
while in
helping students learn about different
aspects of drug repurposing and drug
designing with all of his experience so
he'll be talking on 21st april uh it's a
it's a tentative date right now but uh
yes i mean we have uh we have the
session coming up on drug repurposing
followed by that we have another session
by dr ajeet khammad who has 25 years of
experience on pre-clinical drug
discovery and he'll be talking about the
advancements that he has been following
with with the discovery come
thinking of the huge experience that he
has and also uh
looking at what is going on and how this
entire industry
has evolved from uh from doing virtual
screening and
high cost screening to now more targeted
screening and with less and less cost so
you'll be also discussing about
precision medicine which is one of the
key and hot topics in uh in healthcare
right now so after this session uh
we have an industry panel uh group where
we are going to discuss about the job
opportunities so many of these
innovators and leaders are are also
recruiters and
and they will be discussing about the
expectations and we will have an open
stage and
we will discuss about the skill sets
that we that one would be requiring
to
look for such opportunities so uh in
april as again i would say that we have
these programs planned for those who are
interested but these will be also
available throughout the summer and
anyone who is interested and is not
available right now could also uh join
these at a later stage in the summer
where we have all other plans and other
programs which will be also piloted and
would be available for anyone to go
through so one of the program which is
one of which helps you perhaps to grow
from
training to develop and working on a
project is research fellowship but for
beginners we have a lot of content on
the tbi info platform and also on the
learner mixed logic that we have been
discussing
and actually uh these these are these
are a great start for anyone who is just
a house a beginner and also for students
and also for faculty to brush up and
utilize them many of these lessons into
their teaching and into their curriculum
so the similarly we have a curriculum
from one of the faculty
which has been now uploaded on the
platform and
i would
appreciate if someone can share the link
of these courses that are free to take
and
to gain basic understanding
and then go for that different meta
guided training so this is how how the
entire pathway looks from basic training
that i just discussed we have advanced
trainings such as the ones that we
discussed before and then we are
discussing about specialization project
work that elia described in such a
beautiful manner and then we have the
project projects and internships this is
the summer research fellowship program
that that we are really excited about
because
this is uh not for a beginner but also
uh i mean we get many students who want
to do work on a project and are
beginners so we have different modules
that are from starting from 45 days to
six months and one year where you're
working on different such big problems
challenges and uh
coming up with a research project
publication and all of that so we have
been working with
a lot of students uh and fascinating
projects many of them we were able to
complete and many of them are online so
i'll just uh quickly tell you that how
it is what it is all about uh without
not taking much of your time so
we are in these programs or in this
program
where it is a research internship a
research fellowship uh where we are
working with students who are utilizing
the tbi info server and learn all this
logic for
doing and developing a project so it all
starts from processing analyzing
annotation integration model and
simulate where we are looking for uh
samples and data from online
repositories that could be patient data
that could be any model data that could
be a cell line and tissue level data and
then there are availability of
phenotypic data next generation
sequencing and all of this so
using all of this data we are trying to
find answers and and in this entire
workflow or entire pipeline
we are developing skills experience
connection and validation most
importantly
so uh the
work
that we do usually does have a lot of
a lot of similarities with drug
discovery and pharma industry and also
health care so drug discovery and
clinical data is something
that
a big data approach would
consider first for example uh precision
medicine is one of one of such example
so our focus is to help anyone who are
interested in such proposals who are
interested to work on research projects
based on their own research ideas and
our team actually helps them develop
that project into a real set of goals
objectives and then uh the analysis
interpretation and then writing so this
entire process is uh is
for students it's it's really beneficial
because what they get from this is a
real
real experience working on real data
sets uh facing the challenges writing
and developing such skill sets to
present and also to record their
experience
and for also getting an opportunity to
work on industry projects so many of our
research follows fellows are also hired
for industry projects where we are
working with several of these research
labs and industry
where we are working on big data sets
and there are a lot of opportunities on
those projects that students get after
learning about this entirely and doing
uh
it themselves by one first-hand
experience so
the research consultation is a weekly
research consultation that we do where
we have cohorts uh for a different
research based on different research
interests based on you know uh
university
uh based on um
based on specializations
such as uh neuroscience so we have an
alzheimer's group where a group of
researchers and students are working on
exploring data sets and finding answers
we have a spaceomics research group
similarly these are also like um
independent projects that anyone
independently can work on so we have a
lot of independent
participants who are working on their
research projects and doing some work on
uh
on a specific uh for a specific degree
or for a specific training for example
with emitting art where we have this
scientific program and also other
research internships where students are
completing their internship as well as
uh getting recognition and uh
collaboration with their faculties
leading to uh more outcomes such as
project publications and henceforth so
uh we have a lot of participants who
have completed
without any knowledge of you know they
started their journey without any
knowledge of
big data bioinformatics and all of that
and they were able to
like really do really well within a
short period of time so even we have
students who completed their research in
three months period period of time and
students who were able to complete their
project
in six months period of time but uh
after completing the basic training so
the basic training is very important for
this to to achieve to get some of these
achievements to get some of these
outcomes
so
i would recommend you to take follow the
path that we demonstrated and
that could help us
to help you more and more and
if you are working already working on
one of these
areas and you have a prior experience of
bioinformatics
then you can directly work on a research
project
so for beginners there are there are
resources and training available for
intermediate there is just there are
resources and training available and for
advanced also there are resources and
training available so we similarly have
plans in may for where we are
going to pilot these programs getting
started bioinformatics in our python
space or makes infectious diseases so
i'll be looking forward to meeting you
again if you have an opportunity to join
any of these programs that would be
great because these are the
basic programs and where you start
developing all of these uh skill sets
and explore more and throughout the
summer we will be working on research
fellowship so research fellowship is one
such program that you can join anytime
there is no time limitation but the the
limitation there is the skills like if
you are at an intermediate level that
would be the best time to join the
research fellowship if you have gone
through some of the basic material and
understand how to utilize the t-bind for
server gone through some project
examples to yourself because we have
prepared them with one one objective
that objective is to to make you like to
to prepare you for all the challenges
that are you that you are going to face
in this research journey so i hope this
information was useful for many of you
and we will see uh uh
see you together collaborating on some
research ideas and uh training so i was
it was really great to see you all now
i would like to
pass this stage to sunalika to help you
with the registration or at least to
show you how the registration process
works
thank you so much
and now i would like to take you all one
by one uh
let me share the link yes
i'll be taking you all on the program
page of each one of the program that we
discussed today so this is the first
program page that is introduction to
bioinformatics
now those who are interested to get
themselves enrolled for introduction to
bio informatics program to get started
with bioinformatics and the topics that
we discussed today so this is the
program page that you can visit and
learn more about the program schedule
now when you scroll down you will be uh
able to look at the schedule of the
whole program that we have designed for
you to get started with bioinformatics
so we have uh six sessions in total the
dates have been mentioned the session
title has been mentioned the topics and
also the associated resources i
mentioned now what are these resources
all about these resources are actually
lessons of various courseworks on the
portal itself and just after explaining
after taking you through the program
page i'll be also taking you through the
portal and tell you how you can navigate
the portal and make the most out of the
resources that are
available there
okay so we have the first session on
april 11 and
then uh then the second session is on
april 18th which is about introduction
to genomics snapping and sequencing uh
visualization
and the third session uh in the third
session we're talking more about
transcriptomic data analysis that that
is on april 25th
on second may we will be taking you from
an understanding of transcriptomic data
analysis to differential gene expression
analysis and also the biological
interpretation of the data and then on
may 6 we'll be talking more about
introduction to biomedical data science
and learn some aspects of machine
learning uh in application to various
types of data that we would have been uh
discussed till then and also then we'll
talk about
bioinformatics project examples based on
machine learning for ngs data on may 9th
so we'll be touching upon upon all the
various aspects of multi-omics data
types and also we will be discussing
about the techniques that could be
applied to analyze and work with these
different omics data types and
interpret some meaningful biological
insights out of this data
okay now how do you register yourself so
to register yourself for the
introduction to bioinformatics program
if you scroll down
you will be able to look at three
different levels or i'll call it
subscription levels
we have our level that is a bigger level
now uh this is this level uh will give
you the access to the
live group sessions that we'll be having
and also you will be able to take your
questions uh be a part of a community
and get all the resources access to all
the resources
an intermediate level will give you an
access to one-on-one mentor support uh
rather than group meetings you will be
able to share your one-on-one uh live
meetings with your mentor and take your
questions ahead and in the advanced
level you'll get some extra time to work
on your research project and also have a
research proposal in hand that could be
taken ahead and
give you some really good outcome that
could either be a research publication a
poster presentation or a
project to be submitted in your college
if you are a certain from your art from
a bachelor's or a master's degree as a
requirement of your uh last semester
some of them have it as a requirement to
complete their last semester so you will
get some extra time to learn a program
and then apply it to a project maybe to
sit with the mentor and uh
have your research project designed
okay so these are the three different
levels or i'll call it subscriptions
beginner intermediate and advanced
now i've explained these three
subscription levels so i'll keep it
constant for the other programs as well
i'll just take you through the syllabus
of the other two programs that we
discussed about
so then we have um
transcriptomics program and then we have
um the introduction to game informatics
and drug discovery program as well now
in the transcriptomics data analysis
program the program starts on 12 april
and will end on 12th may and the
schedule of the program is mentioned on
the program page
now uh again there are six sessions for
the program as well
you can go through the schedule of the
program here and again we have three
levels beginner intermediate and
advanced
uh where you will get some extra extra
time to work on your uh like propose a
research question in the advanced level
get one-on-one mentor support in the
intermediate level and in the beginner
level you have the access to usual
sessions and then coming to introduction
to game informatics and drug discovery
program this program will be starting on
19th april and will end on 19th may
and the schedule of the program is again
here on the program page let me just
share the link in the chat box
and you can learn more about the
schedule on the page itself
and talking about the program enrollment
again the same three levels are here too
and to pick the level that you would
like to opt for you can click on the
select option button and enroll yourself
now i would like to quickly take you all
to the
portal
login button first of all so those who
have not yet created an account for
themselves on the portal they can do so
by clicking on the login button it's
very easy to create an account for
yourself
let me just log out and give you a quick
demo you need to just click on the login
button now either you can create an
account for yourself simply by clicking
on on create an account and putting in
the details that are asked or you can
also create an account for yourself or
sign up by
opting any one of your social media
accounts i'm doing it so i'll be doing
it by clicking on my
google accounts
and this will help me login
i'll also put the links to the portal in
the chat box
thank you so much oh just me for the
link
okay now once you have signed up on the
omixlogicloan portal
the first thing that you need to do is
update your profile so click on the
email id in the menu bar
and add a profile picture
your name should be in title case make
sure that your name is in title case
because this is the same format that
will reflect on the certificate
please connect your social media
accounts and add a brief file about
yourself
a brief file could include your
education or your research background if
you are a researcher and also your
research interests that you would like
to work on
and once you are a part of any of these
three programs that i just
showed you the program pages you will be
able to see the badge of the very same
program on your profile now clicking on
this badge will
take you through the uh program page
now also on the very same program page
you will be able to look at the
recording of the session uh here in the
page itself after the session is
completed now let's say you're not able
to attend the session like because any
of your commitments or you want to
revisit the
the topics that were discussed by the
mentor in the session you can get back
to the program page and look at the
recording the recording will be there
for you throughout the program
okay now coming back
now uh all the lessons that i showed i
was talking about the associated online
resources and and i told you that these
are actually the lessons on the
omixlogic learn portal now where are
these lessons located
and how can we monitor your progress
with these lessons so this is the place
the profile itself where you can see
your progress what you have been
completing or working so far and also
you can see how many lessons you have
completed for each of the courses and
get a certificate once the full course
is completed now let's look where these
courses are actually located so if you
click on the courses button you get a
list of courses example projects uh
which are based on um various omics data
types which includes transcriptomics
meta genomics epigenomics and genomics
and then you also have various example
projects now these example projects are
actually designed to give you an essence
of how the type of comics data
you learned about could be applied to
answer the techniques that you learned
about could be applied to answer a
research problem in hand
so now how do you look go through the
various courses that are present
on the portal just click on the courses
tag which is here on the right side in
the various stacks and clicking on the
courses tag will help you look at
various courses that are there on the
portal right and you you can get started
with the course of your choice
we recommend that you get started with
introduction to bioinformatics for those
who come from a non-bioinformatics
diagram and then also we have a
coursework that is bytes and molecules
that you can go through and get
introduced to various omix data types
and specialization tracks and last but
not the least as i uh was talking about
the example project so if you just click
on the project you will be able to have
a look at all of these example projects
which are actually the applications of
various courseworks here on the portal
so that was it about how you can
navigate on the portal and if um
any
on any of the links that you share in
the chat box but you would like to
revisit it later and enrolled for the
program then you can click on the
programs icon in the menu bar itself and
you'll be able to look at the various
programs here and simply click on it
this will redirect you to the program
page and get yourself enrolled to get
started
so that was it if we have any questions
you can please put them in the chat box
and we are here to
uh
guide you through
okay so himanshi is asking about the fee
structure for the research fellowship
program okay so for the research
fellowship program himanshi uh
and you need to visit the research
fellowship page you just need to click
on the research button here
and this will take you to the research
fellowship page
now when you click on learn more you
will be able to learn more about the uh
duration of the research fellowship
program that you can enroll for and and
also the structure of the program and if
you click on get started you will have
here two subscription levels beginner
and advanced now in the beginner level
you will be able to get the access to
the education cloud pipeline and in the
advanced level you will be able to get
the research access to research cloud by
appliance and uh
there's a slight difference between
these two subscription levels so in the
beginner type of subscription level we
generally refer to
the
various big data repositories that are
present so we extract data from these
repositories and we uh work on them
analyze and interpret the results right
and in the advanced level of
subscription that is more recommended
for people who are actually generating
their own data maybe if they are a phd
or postdoc fellows and they have their
own data which is generated in their
labs and they would like to uh work with
it so what happens in the advanced level
we give them an ftp account where they
upload their data and then they work
with it uh in their research project
duration right so you can uh figure out
whatever requirement you have based on
the type of data analysis that you would
like to take further for your research
project and that is the slight
difference that i told you
okay now there are two options either
you enroll for a three month program or
you enroll for six months program
now you can see uh the three months
subscription level is like here and if
you pick a six month one then you have
the options placed here
now the uh thing is if you want to get
enrolled first of all you can mail at
marketing as it on project.com
either you can enroll yourself directly
or if you
opt for a scholarship then you can fill
out the scholarship form
i'll just take a second and i'll share
the scholarship form in the chat box
yes
here is the scholarship form
you can fill out the scholarship firm
and
our team will review your application
and then we'll get back to you on it
right you can also mail us directly at
marketinglogic.com
[Music]
okay thank you
uh do we have any more questions
yes
uh we have a question i think the person
has not named himself or herself and has
the name by the device yes you can
definitely go through all these
resources without a linux system not
without windows definitely you need a
browser to go through these
various resources on the portal
yes nadia the sessions are recorded if
you have an internet connection and
stability issue you need not worry about
it because
we have everything recorded and we share
the recording with you and also we have
slack channels so you can go through the
recording and you will be a part of a
slack channel and you can take your
questions there in the
groups at your own uh pace you can go to
the recording and whenever you get time
you can just put your question about the
session in the group and the mentor will
reply to you uh based on their
availability
and we can also uh
take your questions in these live
sessions definitely
so
me
to get started
you can go to the courses tab
and there are various courses here on
the portal let me just show you the free
resources to get you started because we
have a lot of
students and researchers as well who
come from different fields and not
computational biology specifically but
they wish to get started with
computational biology at some point in
their research or to begin with their
career
uh this is one particular course that is
introduction to bioinformatics this is a
free of cost course which you can go
through and get an essence of what is
bioinformatics and what is its role in
translation healthcare and why should
you actually bother doing bioinformatics
as simple as that right and the other
coursework is bytes and molecules that
is again absolutely free of course in
this coursework you will be able to uh
understand these various omics data
types that we discussed genomics
metagenomics epigenomics transcriptomics
and also some of these specialization
tracks like um precision medicine space
omegas and also infectious diseases and
get started with art
and also there are various other
courseworks too
in which
few of the lessons like first few
lessons actually of course that you can
go through and ah except that you have
person style lessons uh for which you
would be required to be a part of the
program and take metro guidance to
understand these technical concepts
uh
real me bad yes you can learn from your
device definitely
uh the way raghav sir and ojaspi have
explained it to you
yes you need to enroll yourself for um
individual summer program whichever
program you are interested in or the
research fellowship program
and because taking the subscription
level will help you get the access to
the resources that we have discussed so
far and also to the mental guided
sessions
okay so uh do we have more questions
if we have any questions please put them
in the chat box so that we can answer it
for you
and if not
at the moment when you can anytime feel
free to please email us at marketing at
the rate omixlogic.com
[Music]
uh can i chime in for a while sonalika
there's a little bit of confusion over
what i'm posted in the chat
so uh the lessons can be learned you can
go over the lessons you can understand
what the lessons tell you what the
asynchronous materials tell you even you
can go over the recordings also
yeah also all the resources using any
device that you can get your hand to
hand on
but
to get to completely understand the
logic behind these analysis you will
have to uh
set up pipelines you will have to
understand um
you'll have to upload the data or you'll
at least have to upload links to the
pipeline and download the download
preferably download the output files
open these tables output files which
could be
tables or which could be pictures
on your device and then
perform some sort of basic
analysis like filtering like sorting so
these filtering sorting and to explore
the table tabular output that the
pipelines are
giving you or are giving you giving
access to you cannot be performed
unfortunately on on every tablet that
you can get hands on on some really
high-end ones you can actually
download the tables and then open it up
and do some basic analysis like
filtering sorting and some very basic
plotting that's what we do
but for these yeah i think it is
recommended that you get
access to computer at least at the face
where you are
running pipelines and trying to copy or
trying to download the output files and
exploring the output files as you
follow along with the synchronous or
asynchronous materials so that's what i
wanted to clarify because there has been
yeah multiple different uh versions of
answers that we actually told you
thank you very much
over to you sonica
thank you so much for the clarification
and i have a question in the chat box
regarding the certificate yes all these
programs are certified so there are two
possibilities for the certification let
me share my screen and go back to my
profile as i was
talking before about the certification
process so you see when you complete a
particular program once the program is
completed so i'm just giving you an
example of the previous programs that we
had like workshop symposium etc so once
these programs are completed you can
view your certificate in the uh in your
profile itself
just click on the view certificate
button
uh i think because of minutes taking
time and then simply download it yeah
it's up so simply download this and then
you can share your achievement wherever
you would like to
so that was about the certification
process and
uh do you have any other questions
i think some participant has uh please
uh keep your cell phone mute if you have
any questions then you can annual
yourself
okay so if you have no more questions
yeah i think i see one more question
which asks about online softwares aren't
enough to analyze for the analysis so
most more often more often than not what
you see in in an online software
environment is
the software's i mean let's not call
them softwares most of the most of the
methods that you find online are
actually tailored for that specific data
set or that specific source organism and
they're not generalized as such so what
we actually offer you is our analysis
methods or our
way of categorizing these multiple
different
pipelines multiple different algorithms
and softwares and then um
giving them to you so that you don't
have to worry about n number of
different settings that you have to set
every time that you want to install so
almost all of the algorithms that you
see online for omix data analysis
involves
installation and
understanding of at least four or five
different algorithms with as many as
different parameters so what we offer
you is
a set of pipeline different pipelines
that will take
specific paths or specific sequence of
these algorithms that can be employed
for the different omics data that you
can analyze with so what what
the bioinformatics
big data bioinformatics platform gives
you is it will give you uh options to
set parameters only that are necessary
to be set for the mixed data so you
don't have to worry about the other
parameters at all and if at all if you
want to set these parameters and we give
you explanation on what is the expected
number or what's expected value and
where are you expected or where are you
required to find this specific uh
parameter and set these parameters so
these information that you will not find
easily on the online softwares and the
more more often than not you will have
to try
four five different sequences and in the
end
you are going to uh
spend lot of time trying to
read the manual and trying to uh
curate uh different algorithms for the
data that you have
so that that's that's basically main
difference between what what's already
available out there and what we actually
offer you
so of course as i mentioned you can take
the bauta algorithm and then try it out
on your computer but of course to run
bowtie you need at least
a computer with 64 gb or 128 gb ram so
you don't have we be more more most
likely we might not get access to those
high performance computing and even if
we have a very competent computers then
you will have something like
you have to install the
install the softwares manage
dependencies and
multi i mean trust me i've gone through
all those different routes and it's not
fun
trying to uh
yeah trying to solve dependency issues
so yeah
and i yeah i can hand it over to
sonalika again
if you have any other queries
and somebody asks if there is a
certificate
issued uh yes i have taken that question
perfect yes sir
okay so thank you so much everyone for
joining today's webinar and uh for any
queries feel please feel free to reach
out to us at marketing other at
omixlogic.com
and we also uh share with you the
recording of today's webinar and it was
nice to have you all with us and you can
get
get back to us for getting enrolled and
getting started thank you bye have a
nice